joining us now gold star mom Karen
Vaughn
I have known you for many many years you
are the mother of Aaron Vaughn he was
one of 30 servicemen he died who's part
of extortion 17 you've met President
Trump you also when your son's body was
being brought back you have a story to
tell was president Trump empathetic to
you did he show empathy 46 he was
extremely empathetic Shawn I've not only
met him once I've met him twice he sat
with him his gold star families met with
him before the election and then he also
invited our family to the White House
for a gold star families dinner and
ceremony a ceremony that he plans to
continue I understand till he brings in
a tremendous number of gold star
families across this country he is
extraordinarily empathetic to the gold
star family what you at the time and the
families this was at the time happened
in Afghanistan in August of 2011 and it
was the largest loss of military life in
a single day you and the families then
asked President Obama he you said he was
welcome to come when the bodies were
being received but you did have a
request the families had a request what
was it the request was no press no
pictures that this was a solemn very
private engagement and that was agreed
upon and then unfortunately what
happened is the next morning we found
out that he had he did have a
photographer there with him that night
and we didn't think too much about it
but the next morning the picture of him
saluting our sons caskets was plastered
all over the media the White House staff
had released that photograph and had
dishonored our you know our very simple
request to just let this moment be
private our sons died 7,000 miles away
from us and we just wanted to welcome
their bodies home so President Obama
didn't honor your request which is a
little unbelievable to me he also didn't
call some families which we discovered
too and then we learned in the case even
his own general when general Kelley lost
his son I don't want to drag into the
politics of this but you did meet
President Trump and then you hear that
general Kelley wasn't called and then
you see one of the biggest Trump haters
attacking the president on this very
issue that touches your families
so deeply my question to you is do you
sense this is being politicized and your
reaction to it it's definitely being
politicized this is nonsense to even be
discussing this Shawn I know you're
frustrated by it I sense it in your tone
and I appreciate that this is utter
nonsense when a person calls a family
member whose loved one has just died
overseas it is an act of Honor I did not
agree with President Obama his policies
or anything else but I did respect the
fact that he came to Dover to meet our
families so you know you just have to
respect the extension of grace and mercy
and love and respect that's given and to
turn this into a political stump for
this congresswoman who seems to me to be
desperate for attention is a gross
undermining of the loss that's been
that's been suffered by this incredibly
brave with to just jump on board and
they don't put in context how much this
congresswoman hates the president Karen
I've gotten to know you love you you're
my thoughts and prayers always thank you
for being with us
love you too Sean thank you